the second purge movie takes place one
year after the original and unemployment
has risen from one percent in the
previous movie to five percent
this may be a reflection of the economy
in the world of the purge worsening
despite the claims by the political
group the new founding fathers of
america that the purge benefits the
economy as we now know firsthand it
turns out massive amounts of death
actually isn't so great for the economy
as a whole save for a select few of the
world's wealthiest companies in our
world walmart and amazon are the rare
examples of thriving businesses but in
the world of the purge it's all about
weapon manufacturers this all plays into
the commentary
that anarchy makes about gun violence in
the us to learn the true meaning behind
everything that happens in anarchy
including how universal took a shot at a
rival film studio
stick around to the end of this video
welcome to things you missed first part
the original purge introduced the new
founding fathers so this time we learn a
little bit more about them and we meet
their opposition
revolutionary group headed up by carmelo
johns jon surmises that the purge is a
tool to funnel money upwards to the
upper class the politicians and their
rich donors it is the poor who are most
likely to die on purge night as they are
unable to protect themselves
this makes it appear as if the nffa is
doing a great job by cleaning up the
streets and reducing taxes that go
towards welfare to take care of those
people
those rich political donors that i
mentioned likely consist of two groups
those who sell security as we saw in the
previous movie and those who sell
weapons which we start to see in this
movie
everyone wants to get in on the
so-called holiday sales trend
even the street vendors try to sell eva
weapons as she walks home telling her
she needs them as protection as casually
as tourist shops might tell vacationers
that they need an item to commemorate
their trip
and these are the same stalls that you
might find in la selling t-shirts and
postcards the use of the purge as a
money making tool in 2023
is really only a slight exaggeration of
what goes on in real life where
organizations like the nra donate tens
of millions of dollars per year to fund
election campaigns for politicians who
will do what they say
so when these weapons are used for the
inevitable acts of terror
gun companies can rest assured that
their politicians won't do anything to
hurt their weapon cells
the satirization of american gun culture
is a thread that runs through the entire
movie and seemingly the rest of the
series but there are also other themes
and connections you might not have
noticed let's get into the things you
miss
[Music]
during the opening title we see the seal
of the new founding fathers of america
it's very reminiscent to the great seal
of the united states the difference is
being that in the nffa seal the eagle is
holding an assault rifle and a machete
instead of arrows in an olive branch the
wings are much more rigid
like jet wings and the glory of stars
which originally represented the 13
american colonies coming together
is thoughtfully replaced with two knives
coming together a symbol of unification
replaced with a symbol of conflict the
first character we meet is eva a
waitress taking care of a customer named
mr sabian
how is everything mrs sabian great as
always savion is a name that director
james demonico often includes in his
movies as a director's trademark but it
has a special meaning in the purge
franchise where it's often tied to a
character with some kind of link to the
nffa
in the purge mr sabian was one of the
neighbors who went hunting during the
purge and in the prequel the first purge
arlo sabian is the nffa chief of staff
this time mr sabian is played by an
actor named
vik sabian there's another potential
reference on the tv the new scroller at
one point reads a drive along oregon's
coast reveals soaring
sand dunes which may be a nod to the
production company platinum dunes
the news anchor also says that more
people will partake in this purge than
ever before
i mentioned in the last episode that
this is the case in seemingly every
purge that we've seen and in anarchy
we find out why roll it tonight we take
lives
we make things manageable for us
unfortunately the citizens aren't
killing enough though we supplement it
all
to keep things balanced as commencement
draws closer a married couple
shane and liz rush to get shelter and
see people putting out blue batisias
which the previous movie explains to be
a sign of support for the purge
we don't see them as much as you would
expect in this movie which may be
because of a shortage caused by drought
as explained in an article on the nffa
website you can also spot men putting up
plywood and this shot is a powerful
visual representation of what carmelo
johns preaches about the poor being the
ones that suffer the most during the
purge while the nfa can afford to sit
back behind their high-tech security
systems while eva is walking home you
can get a slight glimpse of a poster
advertising
the suspension of emergency services
during the purge which is actually just
a movie poster from the ad campaign of
the original movie
in that film we encountered one group of
purgers that wore creepy nondescript
masks
shane and liz encounter a new group who
travel around on motorbikes skateboards
and a large van
some of them have religious iconography
on their masks or faces the last movie
did have a little bit of evidence of the
purge starting to become a religion with
the crazy neighbors holding hands and
reciting something like a prayer the
emergency broadcast ending with this
blessed be our new founding fathers and
america
a nation reborn and maybe even the
choice of flowers the blue batisias
being a reference to baptism the
symbolic form of purification and used
in some religions it goes along nicely
with a phrase commonly chanted by
purgers
purge and purify say it with me
anarchy takes the religious parallels to
the next level i think the idea is that
by making violence into a religious
experience the nffa hopes that people
will look past their morals and blindly
accept it as an okay thing to do
many people follow religion to help
guide their morality but i'm sure you
can also think of examples of those who
use their religion as an excuse to
justify horrible behavior
like those nutcases who try to ban
horror movies those people have strayed
so far from the lights
we see the purge become more and more
intertwined with religion throughout the
first three purge movies carmelo calls
this out in one of his rants
we no longer worship at the altar of
christ
muhammad yahweh we worship at the altar
of
smith and wesson smith wesson is a
firearm manufacturer next is a sniper
woman acting as a herald from a rooftop
her speech is rife with religious
entitlement
she says i'm doing god's work he uses an
earthquake a virus the masses nourish
and flourish
i am that virus tonight i am a one-woman
plague and you're all in my past
i am the holy trinity i am the father
son of a
and holy sh and my mp9 silver tipped
auto magnus
the right arm of the free world and the
left hand of god in flaming fire i take
the heads of them
that know not god and the host of the
purge gala at the end of the movie
describes one of the weapons that she
considers her favorites
it is so precise
it's as if god had crafted it himself
and that brings me to the purge
countdown billboard when hacked by
carmelo's group it glitches out and
momentarily reveals a hidden message
[Music]
probably the most iconic new villain in
this second purge movie is
this guy who for obvious reasons i'll
just call godhead it seems that he's
labeling himself as a god a decider of
who lives and who dies
halfway through the annual purge
carmelo's revolutionary group taps into
one of the video feeds of the countdown
to deliver a message to the people about
the nffa
his video contains a lot of distortion
and visual glitches which seems to be
purely for aesthetic purposes one of the
glitches shows new founding father
donald talbot and if we pause right as
it happens the word evil is written
across his forehead
in the same spot godhead has written the
word god other subliminal messages in
this presentation include a message
reading frick the purge and a protest
sign that says where corruption begins
wcb may stand for workers compensation
board the state agency that provides
benefits to those who get injured during
work we never hear anything
more about this but based on what we do
know it's not hard to come to the
conclusion that the nfa is using the
purge to take out people that were
injured on the job so that they don't
have to pay them this would be yet
another example of the purge
disproportionately affecting the working
class
speaking of which you know we don't have
a whole lot of time before commencement
shane
all right we'll be fine i promise he
would not be fine
the last character we meet is leo barnes
these articles on the wall tell us that
he's the new jeff denlon and if you look
closely you'll notice this drunk driver
who hit his son was let off the hook
just
two weeks ago around the same time that
leah would have disabled the man's
security system
two weeks ago i came here and i disabled
his back barricade that's what we're
doing here
by the way we spend most of the movie
wondering how barnes got all of his
awesome combat skills when he drives out
of the garage it looks like he's got a
cop car
with extra metal armor covering the body
when he comes face to face with this guy
at the end he says they looked up his
info and he refers to him as sergeant
so it seems like barnes learned to kick
because he used to be a police sergeant
when the purge is about to begin shane
is still optimistic
don't worry we'll figure something out i
promise promise
i do not think that he knows what that
word means speaking of which when eva
and her daughter callie have their
apartment invaded by the sweaty guy from
their building he seems a little
confused on the name of his favorite
government tyrants calling them the
newfound fathers
it's my right credit to me
by the newfound fathers maybe he was
confusing them with a certain late 90s
early 2000s pop punk act but i just had
to point this out
because it seems to have predicted this
whole 2020 phenomenon known as the karen
meme where these people film someone
breaking the rules and then that person
freaks out and claims they have the
right to do whatever it is that they're
doing and usually cites made up
information and makes a huge scene
to get my order and i have a right
the name karen is thought to be a
reference to a character from the movie
mean girls but there can also be man
karen so this guy streaming about how
killing is his right and incorrectly
citing the name of the group that gave
him that right
seems to be an almost simpson-esque
prediction of events later to come
hopefully this isn't one of those cases
of life imitates artha i did find a case
of
art imitates art when the characters
make it to tanya's house the news
coverage they have playing on the tv is
the same channel that james sandon
watched a year prior
even though this takes place a year
later the new scroll at the bottom has
the exact same text as the first movie
about parliament's criminal imprisonment
measures and the comedian copyrighting
and catchphrase
also it turns out that shane getting
shot makes liz realize how much he cares
about it
i got shot oh are you gonna use this
excuse for the rest of my life
at least the rest of the night well i
guess this time they were both right as
the group travels through the financial
district they come across the remains of
a man who had been purged there's a note
left on him that says
here hangs stockbroker david newstatter
stole our pensions
now he's gone however david neustadter
is no stockbroker he's a horror film
executive producer in fact he's one of
the most prolific horror film producers
of the last decade he's responsible for
all of the biggest hits made by
universal studios rival studio warner
brothers the spelling of the name is way
too specific
clearly universal studios or director
james demonico feels that new statters
stole something from them and they're
quite bitter about it
i'm not sure what that something is
maybe there were early talks to make the
conjuring a universal slash blumhouse
movie and a new statter swooped in and
secured that two billion dollar bag for
warner brothers or maybe demonico
pitched something to him and then one of
his future movies was a little too
similar to his idea
if anyone knows what this beef might be
about let me know in the comments the
climax of the movie would involve our
characters being kidnapped by godhead
and his crew and sold off to be victims
in this life and death stakes laser tag
arena but there's something interesting
about the soundtrack
in this sequence
after being kidnapped and sold to rich
nffa associates who hunt people for
sport the main group is put on display
to be sold off along with three other
victims
and to add credibility to carmelo's
theory all three of them are dressed in
clothes you'd typically see on a
homeless person
also the music being played during this
gala is a classic piano piece by chopin
much like how the series opens with a
montage of purging sets to a classic
piece by wc
after shane is picked off by one of the
bad guys speaking of potentially stolen
content the soundtrack here sounds
exactly like a green day song
[Music]
[Music]
oh wow the lyrics fit too and that in
itself is funny because 21 guns has a
melody from
full house roll it
[Music]
so yeah that's how the purge anarchy
connects to full [ __ ] house
the team that helps leo and the others
escape is aided by dante bishop from the
last movie they command you a vehicle in
the parking lot
at the beginning leo was ordering two
innocent people to get out of his car
essentially leaving them to die in the
purge but now he's ordering two bad
people to do the same
it's only been 12 hours but his
experiences on this night have already
started to shape his morals
and about 40 minutes later we see
evidence of his character development
again when he decides to let his son's
killer go free
i guess we don't technically know that
he was ever planning to kill him i mean
maybe he was just going to give him a
stern talking to
but most likely he had malicious
intentions but changed his mind
after coming out of the house he's
finally hunted down by this guy who's
known as big daddy
not that big daddy not that big daddy
that's big daddy
it's here that barnes learns that the
nffa interferes with the purge and this
may have been the moment that inspired
him to fight against the nffa by going
into security work and protecting their
political opponents as seen in the next
movie the final siren sound in leo is
rushed to the hospital i think we now
know that this is maybe the most
unrealistic part of the purge since
we've now seen how bad things can get
when hospitals all reach capacity
in the credits there were a few hidden
cameos from the first movie like the
interface of a sand and security system
the group that broke into the sandin's
house and shame sandon himself
at the beginning of this video i
mentioned how the purge anarchy is a
social commentary about gun violence in
the u.s demonico himself has talked
about how it explores the idea that if
there was no governments then what would
dictate our morality
we see that some people will try to take
the law into their own hands we see
those without guns of their own being
the most vulnerable targets but when
given a weapon they fight violence with
violence
because if you can't afford one you
can't really protect yourself through
any other means
the purgers will find you it starts with
the just the gun lovers but we see
participation in the purge grow
year over year as the groups being
gunned down start to retaliate and
ultimately allowing this to go on year
after year causes things to devolve into
complete
anarchy click the video on the left for
more analysis of the purge franchise and
if you love horror remember to subscribe
to cz's world for new horrors every week
ring the death bell for notifications
and i'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive if you don't
want to be purged you should stay home
but if you do have to go out there wear
a mask